hey if you want to show your love for
the seventh at least since and support
this channel at the same time check out
our brand new online store we have
original designs like this esken or
praise the Sun shirt created by Pro
artist Cuusoo mati
you can't find these designs anywhere
else so check us out at anime uproar
calm link in the description fans of the
channel can now use a special discount
code uproar 25 at checkout to receive an
instant 25% off
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and here we go again
now if you're a fan of seven deadly sins
or nanatsu no taizai you probably
already know that the long awaited
second season of the anime just finished
airing in Japan a few months ago so you
were probably shocked and crying tears
of joy when you saw that apparently
seven that these since season three was
already out on Netflix at least that's
what it seemed like when Netflix started
advertising that seven that these since
season three had become available on the
streaming service in October of 2018 but
of course if you look more closely you
will see that this is not season 3 of
the anime at all in fact this is season
2 of the anime the same season 2 that
just finished airing in Japan a few
months ago so how did this confusion
happen how is it possible that a major
global streaming service like Netflix
could blatantly mislabel the seasons of
one of its alleged original series this
confusion dates all the way back to
February of 2017 when Netflix first
claimed to have season two of seven
deadly sins but in fact at that time
there was no season two of the seven
deadly sins anime what Netflix has done
is they took a four Episode TV special
called signs of a holy war and
mislabeled it as season two of the seven
deadly sins back in February of 2017 I
made a video talking about this
confusion and explaining to people that
this is not season 2 of the anime season
2 of the anime had not even been made up
to this point this was just a four
episode TV special that the creators of
the seven deadly sins made to hold the
fans over between the first and second
season so if you think about it for even
a minute clearly this is a show that has
seasons with 24 episodes and a four
episode TV special does not count as a
separate season but as frustrating as
all of this is you can't really blame
people for being confused Netflix as I
said is a major global streaming service
and there is no reason why they should
be mislabeling the seasons of one of the
anime that
claim are their own Netflix originals in
this way let me make this clear for
those of you guys who might not know the
seven deadly sins anime is based on a
manga this manga is the original source
material and the manga is far ahead of
the anime so there definitely should be
a season three sometime in the future
however at this point in time there is
no season 3 there is no release date for
a season 3 and what we have so far is
season 1 24 episodes signs of a holy war
TV special 4 episodes and then season 2
called revival of the commandments which
is also 24 episodes
I hope this clears up your confusion and
I definitely hope that Netflix is going
to step up as a major corporation with
many reliable employees one would assume
and stop mislabelling the shows that
they themselves are claiming are Netflix
originals now it is absolutely true the
Netflix have original shows such as for
example stranger things which they play
a major role in producing and which
premiere exclusively on Netflix
however with shows like the 7th at least
since when Netflix says that this is a
Netflix original it seems that they just
mean that they have the distribution
rights outside of Japan for this
particular series but the fact is that
this series was airing in Japan
independently on Netflix from January of
2018 until the summer of 2018 and it is
only several months after it finished
airing in Japan the Netflix finally
decided to put it up on their website
and make it available legally for
audiences outside of Japan but of course
they mislabeled it as season 3 instead
of season 2 personally I've no idea why
Netflix wait so long to make these anime
available to the Western audience they
should be simulcasting them weekly as
each new episode comes out so that
everyone is aware when these anime are
coming out and which season they're
actually watching Netflix already does
this for a whole bunch of Western shows
they simulcast them weekly as they come
out and they've even done it for some
anime like violet ever garden they were
posting new episodes weekly as they came
out in Japan so I really don't know why
Netflix is doing this for some series
but not for others like the seven deadly
sins creating all of this crazy confused
mislabelling and so on the funny thing
in all of this is the Netflix overall is
a great service I use it all the time I
watch a lot of their shows and overall I
love it
however Netflix clearly needs to get
their act together when it comes to
anime you can be mislabelling your own
so-called original shows in this way
earlier this year we learned that
Netflix is going to be investing a lot
more money into anime content which is
great but they really need to get their
act together and stop making these
rookie mistakes like mislabeling an
anime and saying that a season 3 came
out when it's only season 2 I think that
Netflix is a streaming service with all
their brand recognition and global
budget have the potential to absolutely
dominate the Western anime market as
long as they get their act together
sometime soon and guys please start
simulcasting the episodes no one wants
to wait eight months to watch an anime
but let me know what you guys think were
you disappointed when you learned that
season 3 of the seven deadly sins on
Netflix is not season 3 at all and what
do you think will Netflix finally get
their act together when it comes to
anime let me know down below I'd love to
hear from you and I just know that I'm
still gonna see some comments thank you
idiot season 3 is clearly on Netflix it
says so right on the website anyway if
you enjoyed this video you found it
informative and you want to see more
seventh at least sense content on this
channel leave a like to let me know if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
valve if you want to stay up to date on
all the latest information you can also
follow us on Twitter and Instagram and
anime uproar and finally if you want to
support this channel and get some
amazing anime merge so you're not gonna
find anywhere else like this esken or
praise the Sun t-shirt and other awesome
anime designs be sure to check out our
brand new website anime are calm if you
are coming directly from the anime port
channel you can now use the discount
code up for 25 for an instant 25% off
just be sure to type in uproar 25 at
checkout as always thank you all so much
for watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you